you can talk about gun control all you
want okay self-defense is illegal in the
UK it's illegal you think that's moral
even if it resulted in significant death
reduction which it hasn't do you think
it's moral to Outlaw the right to defend
oneself an English homeowner had a toy
gun he detained two burglars in his
house while he called the police the
police arrested the homeowner for a toy
gun it was used to threaten or
intimidate families in Britain have been
ordered by housing officials to remove
children's pools from the gardens
because burglar could drown landlords
told residents they were worried from
surrounding area potential burglar
wandering in at night could trip and
fall in the water there been people
charged for selfdefense all the time